Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Ciao ragazzi, ciao a tutti!
E grazie Flavia, che hai fatto
un'ottima introduzione al talk.
Dunque sarò molto breve,
comincerò dalla preistoria,
nel senso informatico del termine.
Ma non temete, Claudio, non aver paura
finisco nei termini previsti.
Cominciamo dicendo che,
quand'ero ragazzino, era molto raro
trovare qualcuno che ne sapesse
d’informatica e dunque,
come me penso molti altri,
hanno cominciato a cercare di capirci
qualche cosa da soli
nella loro propria stanzetta.
Ricordo ancora benissimo
la prima esperienza:
avevo circa dieci anni;
mio padre mi aveva regalato
un computer di cui
io non sapevo cosa fare.
Allora ho preso, sono andato in cameretta,
ho preso un libro e ho cominciato copiare:
per due giorni, senza interrompere,
ho cominciato a copiare,
a scrivere, scrivere qualche cosa,
dicesi “scrivere codice”.
Dopo due giorni, magicamente,
ho visto un oggetto
comparire sullo schermo,
che prendeva il volo,
e il volo era fantastico,
e il volo non si fermava più!
Ho dovuto staccare la spina
per riprendere il controllo del computer.
È stata una cosa fantastica.
Questa cosa mi ha fatto imparare due cose:
1. che il computer è stupido,
con rispetto parlando.
Bisogna spiegargli tutto, passo passo,
una cosa alla volta.
2. Io non è che ero più furbo,
era soltanto che dovevo metterci
un po' del mio, un po' di ragionamento,
un po' di logica.
Strutturare il pensiero.
E questo era tutto.
E questo mi è semplicemente piaciuto
e ho deciso che la nostra vita insieme
sarebbe stata molto lunga,
perché ci sono e c'erano
tante cose da fare.
Infatti, come ha detto anche prima Flavia,
ci sono moltissime persone oggi
che sono appassionate d’informatica:
bimbi, adulti, adolescenti
e che lo devono utilizzare tutti i giorni,
che lo si voglia o no.
Smartphone, tablet, portatile, computer,
qualunque cosa: fa parte della vita.
Non è più puro e mero appannaggio
dei pochi addetti ai lavori.
Questo fa parte di tutti,
in tutti i mestieri,
anche gli artigiani hanno bisogno
di un computer di fianco.
Dunque c’è chiaramente qualche cosa
che può fare paura.
Può fa paura il fatto
che i nostri ragazzi
siano prigionieri di questa tecnologia,
passivi di questa tecnologia;
è lecito domandarselo.
Ma la risposta è semplice, è: no.
Fa parte dell’evoluzione della vita.
Fa parte dell'evoluzione tecnologica.
Ogni volta che c'è una tecnologia nuova
praticamente bisogna soltanto imparare
a capirne qualche cosa.
Per cui l'unico modo per farlo
è insegnare ai nostri ragazzi
e a noi stessi a utilizzare la tecnologia,
a farla parte di tutti i giorni,
essere parte attiva di questa
e capire come funziona.
E dunque… io ci ho provato, facile?
Non lo so, ma comunque c’ho provato,
ho fatto la mia esperienza.
Ho preso mio figlio, quello piu grande,
ho aspettato che fosse abbastanza grande
che sapesse leggere scrivere,
e che avesse un minimo
di competenze matematiche,
un minimo di ragionamento,
e ho preso il computer,
l’ho messo davanti a me,
ho preso mio figlio
e l’ho messo di fianco a me.
Ho cominciato sbatacchiare sulla tastiera
e ogni tanto guardandolo come per dire:
“Boh, secondo me non capisce,
ma non fa niente”.
Allora intanto parlavo,
dicendo quello che facevo.
Com'è finita?
Benissimo dopo un’ora avevo implementato
una funzione che faceva la simulazione
del lancio di monetine e faceva
la rappresentazione grafica
della probabilità
che uscisse croce o testa.
Fantastico: mi son divertito
come al solito. Mio figlio?
Benissimo anche lui.
Dormiva come un angioletto
sull’angolo del tavolo.
A quel punto mi son detto:
“Peccato, mio figlio, proprio mio figlio
non gli piace l’informatica!
Va be', faremo qualcos’altro nella vita.
C'è tanto da fare, non è un problema.”
Però poi alla fine ci ho ripensato,
ho detto: “Ma non è, che per caso,
sono io che ho utilizzato
il metodo sbagliato?
Magari ci vuole qualcosa
di un pochino più pedagogico,
qualcosa che sia approcci
un pochino di più ai ragazzi.
E allora ho cominciato a cercare.
Primo posto dove sono andato
è stato a scuola:
naturalmente, era un po’
lontano anni luce da quello
che mi aspettavo
di un qualcosa “computer oriented”,
qualcosa che insegnasse a mio figlio
a essere pronto alla tecnologia,
che diventasse amico della tecnologia,
parte attiva di questa.
Dunque, dopo di questo,
continuai a cercare.
Era il 2012, non molto tempo fa,
e a quell'epoca abitavamo in Irlanda
e sono venuto a conoscenza di un movimento
- attualmente una fondazione no-profit
che si chiama CoderDojo -
che forniva, dava, faceva,
corsi gratuiti ai ragazzi
d’informatica, di programmazione.
Fantastico: non ho esitato un attimo,
ho preso i miei figli,
più un po’ dei loro amici,
e siamo andati,
abbiamo conciato a partecipare.
All'inizio, c'era qualcosa di strano,
un metodo che, secondo me,
era un pochino anarchico diciamo:
non c’era un sapientone
davanti alla lavagna
a dettar nozioni e a dire:
“Ragazzi, ora schiacciate il tasto
in basso a sinistra e ora quello in
alto a destra”.
No, non funzionava così.
Funzionava in modo diverso
e ve lo spiego utilizzando le regole
che Barbara di CoderDojo Milano
ha eccezionalmente trascritto.
Allora, CoderDojo si basa su un paio
di regole, attualmente sette,
chiamiamo sette regole d’oro.
Una è: impara facendo, learn by doing.
Allora cosa succede, già prima differenza
tra il mio approcio e quello
che ho visto a CoderDojo.
È il figlio che è davanti al computer,
è lui che è davanti alla tastiera
e comincia a sbatacchiare,
qualunque cosa faccia non importa,
perché il bambino è competente.
Noi dobbiamo partire dalle competenze
che i ragazzi hanno,
permettergli di crescere
e partire da quelle.
OK? Loro lo sanno già quello
che devono fare, in qualche modo.
Poi, naturalmente, a questo punto
non siamo noi che gli stiamo davanti,
ma gli stiamo di fianco e gli seguiamo.
Gli insegnanti, i cosìdetti mentori,
non sono davanti, gli sono di fianco,
girano intorno e si cerca anche
di incoraggiare al limite i ragazzi:
quelli più anzani, quelli magari
che sono già venuti diverse volte
a spiegargli come funzionano le cose.
Questo è semplice, perché,
nella scala dell’apprendimento,
la parte più importante
è quando incominci a insegnare.
OK? Prima ascolti, poi incominci a fare
e quando insegni impari di più,
ancora di più.
Questo è importante.
Poi, gli errori ci piacciono!
I ragazzi hanno il diritto di sbagliare
come in tutte le materie,
come per gli artigiani, è la pratica
la cosa più importante.
La tecnologia non è nulla di diverso.
Bisogna soltanto praticare:
bisogna mettersi lì, scrivere, fare.
Se si sbaglia, qua non è come l'artigiano
del legno, basta un piccolo trucco:
CTRL+Z, tornate indietro e rifate.
Con la tecnologia è facilissimo.
Per cui, dopodiché, è chiaro:
“Non dire no!”, pensiero positivo.
È inutile dire a un ragazzo: “Ah no,
te non sei capace!”
Al limite: “Secondo me potresti
fare meglio!”, oppure:
“Dammi una mano,
che lo facciamo meglio insieme!”
È un approccio completamente diverso,
molto strano e si allontana molto
da quello a cui siamo abituati.
E soprattutto incoraggiamo, i ragazzi,
come dicevo, hanno delle competenze,
ognuno ha le sue, per cui,
qualunque passo faccia,
che lo faccia piccolo o grosso che sia,
fa niente, prendiamolo positivamente
e incoraggiamolo
a continuare su quella strada.
E soprattutto, cosa più importante,
divertiamoci!
Impariamo divertendoci.
E, sopratutto, utilizziamo quello
che è uno strumento un pochino più adatto.
Effettivamente, anche qua,
nella mia esperienza,
ho preso qualche bel editor
di testo informatico
che utilizzo tutti i giorni
ed era un pochino ostico.
Invece ci sono questi tool:
questo, per esempio, è chiamato Scratch
che è stato fatto più di vent'anni fa
dal MIT di Boston,
ed è un tool estremamente grafico,
ma nulla toglie all’importanza
e al metodo con cui
si creano le applicazioni,
cioè il ragionmento informatico.
È come un LEGO: ogni pezzo ha
un suo perché, e il ragazzo impara
automaticamente a metterli insieme,
a comporli in un programma.
E il fatto che ha anche di fianco
subito un ritorno di ciò che vede,
gli permette subito di capire
quello che ha fatto:
se ha sbagliato, se ha fatto giusto
e cosa deve fare.
E questo, piano piano, interattivamente
gli permette di costruire
il suo programma.
Prima di arrivare a CoderDojo Italia,
cosa è successo?
Un anno fa ho preso,
sono partito dall'Irlanda,
sono venuto in Italia.
C’erano già parecchi CoderDojo in Italia.
Però non c'era nella città qui a Trento,
dove mi ero trasferito.
Allora avevo questo desidero,
che i miei ragazzi potessero continuare
a partecipare a CoderDojo,
e dunque ho cominciato a chiedere in giro
e immediatamente, è stata una cosa
facilissima, un entusiasmo incredibile,
in pochissimi giorni abbiamo creato
CoderDojo Trento.
Abbiamo trovato la passione e l’aiuto,
qui in Trentino, di adulti e giovani,
piccoli e grandi, che ci hanno aiutato
e, in pochi mesi, siamo riusciti a creare
cinque centri che, più o meno,
ogni sabato, alternandosi,
danno dei corsi a dei ragazzi.
Qui, soltanto a Trento e dintorni.
E per cui questo è il nostro contributo
a un movimento
che in Italia si sta aprendo sempre di più
e si sta allargando molto velocemente,
perché è importante.
E, come ha detto appunto prima Flavia,
abbiamo avuto anche la possibilità,
un mese esatto fa, di fare,
il 22 di ottobre, un mese fa,
siamo andati alla Camera e al MIUR,
per cui abbiamo fatto una sessione
normalissima con i ragazzi
dentro la Sala della regina
e ci siamo divertiti molto
con i parlamentari.
Un'altra cosa molto importante
che ho imparato, perché questo movimento
è anche un movimento globale,
che si sta espandendo nel mondo.
Però, nonostante la sua globalità,
si focalizza sulla località,
sull'ecosistema locale.
È una rete, per cui, nonostante
la sua globalità tutto si svolge qua,
all'interno del nostro territorio,
con le competenze del nostro territorio.
Perché, come diceva Einstein,
praticamente, è una cosa importante
la diversità e questa
è fatta dal territorio.
Einstein diceva:
“Ognuno di noi è un genio,
ma se tu giudichi una persona,
anzi, un pesce, da come si arrampica
su un albero questo questo crederà
per tutta la sua vita che è uno stupido."
Questa è una cosa importante:
se vogliamo che i nostri figli, oggi,
imparino a utilizzare
la tecnologia in maniera attiva
e, come dice Carmelo
di CoderDojo Bologna:
"CoderDojo trasforma i ragazzi
da utilizzatori passivi
della tecnologia a supereroi."
Non dobbiamo far altro che dargli
i super poteri, io dico, e i super poteri
vengono dalla società nella quale viviamo,
nell'ecosistema.
Per cui dobbiamo fare in modo
da poter preparare i nostri ragazzi
per quando entreranno
nel mondo del lavoro,
che abbiano le competenze giuste.
Le competenze giuste, oggi, ce l’hanno
solamente le persone che utilizzano
la tecnologia per davvero tutti i giorni,
per lavorare, per vivere, per passione.
Perché non possiamo aspettare la scuola,
che avanzi in questo tema.
Dunque dobbiamo utilizzare tutte
le strutture e cercare di creare sempre
di più nuovi spazi, tipo HackerSpace,
ImpactHub, FabLab, Science fair,
ma anche la famiglia stessa,
i centri di ricerca e le aziende locali,
che devono contribuire
a condividere e collaborare
con le conoscenze.
Dunque concludo qui, dicendo che
naturalmente è importante imparare
ad imparare, divertendosi, possibilmente,
perché questo che ho imparato:
che è bellissimo poter, non si crea
niente dal nulla, non si crea
dell'entusiasmo senza dei ragazzi
che imparano divertendosi,
per cui i ragazzi, in pratica,
ci promettono una foresta di creatività.
Dunque vi aspettiamo tutti al prossimo
CoderDojo, perché no, in qualunque città
d’Italia, piccola o grande che siate.
Grazie a tutti!
(Applausi)